je vous parle aujourd'hui de tout
nouveau produit c'est celui là c'est le
readme x55 juste c'est un smartphone à
379 euros un smartphone qui entrent dans
la catégorie du milieu de gamme et sur
lequel vous avez un écran avec un taux
de rafraîchissement de 120 air je sais
pas sans arrière de ça vous passez en
berne
c'est le nom du village que vous allez
avoir par seconde ça veut dire qu en une
seconde
vous allez avoir 120 images alors que la
norme dans cette catégorie de produits
c'est du 60 images par secondes autant
dire que vous en avez deux fois plus ça
va vous apporter beaucoup de fluidité
pour le gaming pour toute l'expérience
multimédia pour le visionnage de
navigation et compagnie donc ça c'est un
problème qui est intéressant et qui fait
plein de jolies promesses c'est ce qu'on
va faire aujourd'hui c'est que mais
surtout vous détailler et je vais vous
dire ce que ce raid me x 55 g20 vous
apportez quels sont les usages est ce
qu'il est fait pour vous est-ce qu'il
faut se positionner quelles sont ses
forces et faiblesses pape mais juste
avant que si ce n'est pas déjà fait vous
invite à venir vous abonner en cliquant
sur le petit bouton rouge que vous avez
juste là vous activer la cloche comme ça
vous serez notifié dès qu'une nouvelle
vidéo arrivera parce que oui si on parle
bien évidemment de smartphones on parle
de take on parle surtout de vous de
votre vie numérique de vos usages dont
il ya plein de se raconter donc cliquer
sur le petit bouton comme ça vous saurez
tout on se retrouve sur un smartphone
qui a une prise en main qui est plutôt
bonne que vous tenez très très
facilement humain alors bon monsieur je
vous conseille quand même c'est lorsque
vous avez un avis gap il peut devenir
reprendra demain vous avez quand même un
grand écran de 55 pouces hd revient dans
quelques instants un design qui est très
sympa avec des reflets qui donne un
effet qui est vraiment premium forcément
ici on a regardé les traces de doigts
rien de bien des collants par rapport à
quoi peut retrouver partout on va
effectivement le module photo le
branding et demi un bouillonnement des
boutons qui est assez mal à vous avez si
important pour venir lui mais l'état qui
fait également office de capteur
d'empreintes digitales et qui
déverrouille extrêmement rapidement
vous avez les boutons de volume qui sont
positionnées de l'autre côté ce qui fait
que lorsque boulton à une main bien
voyez avec mon match l'a trouvé très
très facilement les boutons ja
déverrouille facilement voyons je peux
tenir comme ça on va retrouver en
dessous un haut parleur mono de l'usbc
pour venir recharger votre tiroir de
cartes sim sur une mx-5 hanté par
smartphone le plus léger il fait 2 102
grammes et il existe en deux couleurs
vous avez soit l'argent glace et qu'il
ya des teintes bleutées
je trouve plus que côté argenté et vous
l'avez également envers sauvage et comme
à l'accoutumée chez remy vous avez des
boîtes tout jaune ici avec ce remix 55g
on va avoir plusieurs usages qui vont se
dessiner le tout premier usage ce avec
la partie multimédia partie plus
divertissement aussi bien à renens
surfer sur vos réseaux sociaux
sur internet en regardant du contenu que
ce soit sur youtube sur les flics ce
disney + et compagnie mais également sur
toute la partie gaming puisque c'est
justement tout l'intérêt de cette
machine là un des points les plus
importants pour la partie multimédia
c'est bien évidemment le confort de
visionnage et l'écran vous allez avoir
ici vous avez un grand écran de 6,57
pouces c'est du full hd plus de 1400 par
1080 pixels avec comme je le disais un
taux de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz
vous avez soit la possibilité de le
pousser tout le temps en temps vers ta
tante 60 à venir consommer davantage au
niveau de votre batterie soit de laisser
en 60 hertz sinon vous passez sur la
partie sélection automatique qui va
venir switcher en fonction des besoins
de l'application vous allez utiliser si
par exemple vous ne surfez sur internet
60 hertz suffira largement les par
contre pour des parties gaming de 120
hertz ira parfaitement bien ici vous
êtes un écran qui occupent 80 de 10,4
pour cent de la face avant vous avez
petite bordure sur l'eau sur les côtés
bon vin de garde et comment une bordure
un peu plus importantes sur le banc mais
c'est complètement normal dans cette
gamme de prix mais surtout un écran lcd
que je vous invite à venir un peut
paramétrer en vendant vos réglages vous
allez dans l'affichage et luminosité
mode de couleur l'écran vous reste un
mode vie ça ira très bien ce n'est
modifié par contre la température des
couleurs de l'écran en passons en plus
chaud et je vous invite également à
venir active et le confort des yeux ça
va venir je veux venir votre écran ça
sera vraiment beaucoup plus agréable
puisque je suis dans cette partie vous
avez également un mode sombre ça c'est
vachement bien vous tournez sur remy
ouailles qui fonctionne vraiment bien
tout ça basé sur un android dit ça vous
a effectivement le dark mode et pas mal
de réglages peuvent venir paramétrer vos
icônes pour vos parties de gimme vous
avez également un mode jeu vous avez
quelques paramètres vous pouvez
enregistrer l'écran rejeté les appels
enfin voyez quand même pas mal de
possibilités mais je dirais qu ici un
des points les plus intéressants que
vous avez sur la party gaming et la
partie de performance en règle générale
c'est le fait d'avoir un qualcomm
snapdragon 765 gg pour games un stop
dont je vous ai déjà parlé qui marche
bien qu'ils aient éprouvé qui va être
couplé ici à 6 giga de ram c'est la lp
dédié à 4x très standard vous avez 128
giga de stockage c'est de lui ai fait ce
2.0 une fois de plus c'est quelque chose
de standards dans cette gamme de
produits dont un smartphone qui se tient
vraiment en termes de performances et
qui répondra vraiment à toutes vos
sollicitations mais dans la partie
multimédia il ya aussi un point qui est
vraiment important c'est toute la partie
audio parce que bien évidemment regarder
sur un bon écran c'est bien mais si le
duo d'arrières ne suit pas c'est un peu
moins dérive alors ici on va se
retrouver avec un haut parleur mono que
vous avez juste en dessous ici pas de
haut parleurs stéréo mais à 379 euros
c'est complètement normal donc rien
d'affolant petit bémol qu'on retrouve
souvent dans cette gamme de prix c'est
le fait d'avoir une prise jack is i
really a fait le choix de vous mettre
aucune prise jack donc vous ne pouvez
pas brancher votre casque filaire si
vous en avez néanmoins il ya un point
qui est vraiment intéressant avec ce
produit là c'est que remy a sorti ses
buzz ku et les boeufs pions sont dans
cette petite votre jeune oui
effectivement les chez rémy tout est
jeune une fois de plus et comme ça alors
c'est le tube bien évidemment j'ai déjà
sorti j'ai déjà testé ils ont un
bénéfice qui est extrêmement intéressant
c'est leur prix il coûte 29 euros 99
alors ici on va pas s'étendre à avoir à
la meilleure qualité mais par contre ils
jouent vraiment bien leur rôle parce
qu'en plus sur ce smartphone vous avez
du bluetooth 5.1 toute la petite partie
ici qu'est brillante au milieu bien
c'est un pavé tactile qui vous permettra
de les commander facilement vous les
ouvrez vous appuyez cinq secondes dessus
vous les appéré directement avec votre
smartphone et lorsque vous les utilisez
la fois suivante vous les prenez comme
si dans vos oreilles et se connecte
automatiquement
donc ça c'est vraiment pratique vous
pouvez donc mettre vos petits bugs ku
dans vos oreilles et partir pour l'
aventure pour écouter de la musique
alors c'est effectivement là on aura la
meilleure qualité audio puisque lorsque
vous allez venir écouter directement
avec votre smartphone vous avez
effectivement du son qui sort de votre
haut parleur mais c'est un phoque est
assez médiocre par contre vous avez
quand même du volume derrière vous
écouter vous allez là
si vous essayez de regarder par exemple
une série vous notez comme ça voyez un
avis font ça fonctionne mais c'est pas
là avant la meilleure expérience si vous
voulez vraiment optimisé ça je vous
conseille de venir vous connecter en
bluetooth les boeufs tous ont une très
bonne alternative d'autant plus que je
vous le dirai la fin de la vidéo et bien
vous avez des offres en précommande qui
vous permettent d'avoir vos buzz qu au
faire ça je vous dis juste à la fin donc
rester déconnectés donc ça c'est
vachement cool mais ça vous permet
surtout de dire disposer des petits
écouteurs qui sont pratiques et avec le
pavé tactile pourrait venir play/pause
décrocher un appel raccrocher et mais
lorsque vous appuyez pendant deux
secondes vous allez lancer un mode
gaming avec une latence 219
millisecondes il faut être extrêmement
précis voyance dit où ils sont rangés
ordonné de fuca une petite forme de
galet puis surtout qu'ils sont design et
par josé lévy qu'un designer qui a
notamment collaboré avec hermès
d'autant plus qu'ils ont une
certification ipx4 ils sont résistants à
l'eau donc vous pouvez aller faire du
sport avec sans problème mais vous avez
également ici du dolby atmos alors je
vous lis tout de suite pouvait venir
modifier entre intelligent théâtre jeux
et musique
ça n'a pas changé grand chose lorsque
vous à l'écouté du son au travers
d'autres hauts parleurs mais il ya un
autre usage qui est extrêmement
important est extrêmement répandu
lorsqu'on vient utiliser son smartphone
et notamment celui ci est bien c'est la
partie photo parce que vous n'avez pas
moins de quatre caméras l'arrière quatre
caméras l'arrière c'est bien oui mais en
plus vous avez deux caméras la banque
mondiale vous avez pas moins de six
caméras
vous avez aussi un grand temps de 48
mégapixels touvre f 1.8 vous avez ici un
ultra grand-angle de 8 mégapixels tout
bref 2.3 qu'un champ de vision 219
degrés les vous avez également une
caméra de maquereau de 2 mégapixels
touvre f 2.4 avec un focus à 4 cm et une
caméra de 2 mégapixels qui ouvrait 2.4
une caméra noir et blanc qu'elle apporte
votre portrait tandis qu'à l'avant
planquer jusqu'ici vous avez deux
caméras une de 16 mégapixels qui ouvre à
f 2.0 c'est pas de caméra principale et
le deuxième c'est un capteur 2
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.4 qui est là
pour le mode portrait à l'aréa pourrait
faire de la vidéo jusqu'en capca à 30
images par seconde enquête qui a vous d
absolument aucune stabilisation si vous
de la stabilisation il faut switcher en
1080p à 60 images par seconde tandis
qu'à l'avant pourrait filmer uniquement
en 1080p à 30 images par seconde
voyez sur les caméras de service vous
permettra d'avoir quelques souvenirs
c'est pas non plus d'avoir le meilleur
rendu en terme de vidéo et voici les
résultats à l'irlande à commencer par le
capteur principal et on voit qu'on a un
résultat qui est vraiment convenable et
là dans des conditions de bonne
luminosité ça marche très très bien
on passe sur l'ultra grand temps qu on
ait une différence de colorimétrie une
fois de plus sur mon smartphone dans
cette gamme de prix
c'est normal mais sur dur
visage en ultra grand-angle sens pas
très bien la faire le zoom x 2 ira mais
dès qu'on passe au x 5 c'est pas
terrible ça lisse et pas très beau l x
10 on oublie tout de suite ont
recommencé siècle la caméra principale
ça fonctionne
ultra grand-angle frein à faire foi de
hockey x 5 x 10
on oublie qu'un est la principale août
racontant que c'est exactement la même
chose le foie des hoquets et plus loin
c'est pas beau du tout quelques photos
nuit alors les photos nues c'est assez
intéressant ici les errements de nuit
noire on voit effectivement les étoiles
on devine enfin forcer les bosses et
ouvriers tout à l'heure il ya une
particularité ici c'est que vous n'avez
pas de stabilisation donc dès que vous
allez venir prendre des photos de nuit
si vous n'êtes pas sur un trépied et
s'il ya un seul mouvement tout de suite
vous allez perdre en qualité mais voir
du foot et ce qui est mon cas ici c'est
pas extraordinaire et sur l'ultra
grand-angle le résultat n'est vraiment
pas du tout bon on continue c'est
qu'avec un intérêt principal ça
fonctionnera vraiment des petites fleurs
comme ça c'est très joli en x 2 ça
fonctionne également parce qu'on rate
une fois de plus sur la caméra 48
mégapixels qui va venir en fait croquer
dans l'image mais dès qu'on se rapproche
beaucoup trop et bien ça vient glisser
derrière et c'est pas terrible
l'ultra grand temps que ce sera un peu
moins bon dans cette configuration là
puisque il y aura pas de point qui va se
faire au centre la nacre au
personnellement je suis pas fan
on a vraiment des couleurs qui sont très
très terne c'est pas beau ça vient
glisser le rendu est pas terrible c'est
pas étonnant non plus dans cette gamme
de prix que la macro soit pas génial
mais de toute façon en règle générale
moi je n'aime pas trop leur ont dit
qu'on trouve au niveau de la macro voyez
c'est tout lisse et c'est pas beau c'est
pas naturel il ya un bruit dames
derrière le mode portrait fonctionne
plutôt bien
vient assez bien des tours et le stand
dragonne 765 j'ai fait relativement bien
le taf comme au niveau des cheveux ici
y'a pas grand chose à dire il ya un côté
un peu lisse et mais c'est pas non plus
surprenant le mode portrait en caméra de
celle ci fonctionne aussi relativement
bien et la caméra de celle fille en
extérieur il fait beau ça fonctionne
mais ce qu'on cherche également c'est
d'abord un smartphone qui vous
permettent de durer a minima
on est voir une journée millet deux
journées ça serait vraiment très très
bien et bien ici vous avez une grosse
batterie de 4200 milliampères alors je
vous le dis je vous le dis très très
très souvent l'autonomie de votre
smartphone va varier en fonction de vous
de vos usages de ce que vous allez en
faire si vous paramétrez votre
smartphone en 120 hertz en permanence
forcément l'autonomie sera moins bonne
si vous êtes tout le temps dessus
forcément dont un qui sera moins bonne
si vous jouez à des jeux gourmands
forcément l'autonomie sera moins bon
mais pour un usage un peu moyen vous
donner une journée sans aucun problème
vous pouvez pousser davantage mais une
fois de plus ça dépendra de vous mais un
poc extrêmement important qui est
rassurant c'est d'ailleurs vous avez de
la recharge rapide 30 watts donc si vous
arrivez à un moment où vous êtes un
petit peu limite
et vous avez devant vous un petit quart
d'heure où une petite des meilleurs et
bien pour charger votre smartphone et
vous êtes parti pour une bonne journée
sans aucun problème puisque vous chargez
2-0 à 70 % en seulement 30 minutes et de
0 à 100% en 55 minutes
autant vous dire que ça va vite et là il
ya quand même un côté un peu rassurants
alors ici on est un smartphone qui n'a
aucune certification ip ip 67 et 68 il
n'en a pas
ce qui n'est pas non plus anormale dans
cette gamme de tarifs puisque une
certification coûte de l'argent et
augmenterez le prix du smartphone donc
pour rester compétitifs rien n'y a fait
le choix de me promettre néanmoins vous
avez un verre corning gorilla glass 5 à
la vente qui vient protéger votre
smartphone vous avez quand même à bien
mettre une coque de protection l'arrière
pour éviter les déconvenues
vous avez en plus la possibilité de
mettre deux cartes sim dont une carte 5
g et en plus il va couvrir 12 vendra 5 g
grand pluie alors il faut que la 5g sont
déjà arrivés dans votre pays il faut
vous et ont pu souscrire une offre 5 g
donc si vous l'achetez même si la 5g
n'est pas encore arrivé et bien même si
elle n'arrive que dans un an au moins
vous serez prêt qu'est ce qu'on me
demande souvent je donne les
informations pour le das
ici vous avez un casse tête 2 0
bienvenue 802 watts par kilogramme un
das tronc de 0.7 131 watts par
kilogramme et à dia ce membre de 1,792
watts par kilogramme
c'est un smartphone qui est disponible
dès maintenant en précommande je vous ai
mis tous les liens en bas dans la
description puisque à partir
d'aujourd'hui et jusqu'au 16 août ça
vous laisse très peu de jours mais vous
pouvez y aller eh bien vous avez vos
bottes ue qui sont offerts avec est ce
un smartphone qui sera disponible dans
le commerce à partir du 17 août
remy a été très agressif avec son x 55 g
il vous propose aujourd'hui un
processeur milieu de gamme qui marche
pas très bien on est vraiment dans les
standards du milieu
mais là où ils vont encore plus loin et
bien c'est avec cet écran avec le taux
de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz qu'on
retrouve aujourd'hui sur les flagships
et vous l'avez aujourd'hui la
maintenance euros smartphone à 379 euros
autant dire que c'est un vrai avantage
donc si vous aimez jouer mais vous ne
voulez pas mettre beaucoup trop d'argent
à votre smartphone vous avez un écran
lcd avec un taux de rafraîchissement de
120 air vous avez un smartphone qui est
prêt pour la 5g vous avez quelque chose
qui se tient très bien qui une fois de
plus reste vraiment dans l'adn du milieu
de gamme mais ces propositions que
j'aime beaucoup je trouve vraiment très
intéressant car vous de me dire vous
maintenant ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire qu'est ce que vous pensez
de ce smartphone de rim il x 55 g skill
pourrez vous tentez ce que pour vous
c'est intéressant d'avoir sur un
smartphone milieu de gamme et bien une
proposition avec un écran un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz est ce que
vous voyez l'intérêt pour le gaming
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous jouez et si
vous jouez ce que vous voyez l'intérêt
et si vous ne jouez pas est ce que vous
voyez également l'intérêt est bien par
exemple sur instagram pour venir scrollé
et pour avoir plus de fluidité sur votre
smartphone et dites moi tout ça bien
évidemment en bas en commentaire quant à
lyon on trouve extrêmement rapidement on
reprend à fond il ya plein plein plein
plein de choses et même cet été même au
mois d'août et en septembre sont
européennes pas la tête ne s'arrête pas
avec plein de nouveautés plein d'actus
donc ça va être extrêmement coule sur
ceux plus embrasse nous on s'envoie
beaucoup d'amour et je donne rendez vous
prochainement pour utiliser directement
à parler de teck a très vite ciao ciao
[Musique]